Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today
again to talk about languages.
And today I want to talk about the Russian
language and the Ukrainian language.
And I have a special guest, Ksenia
Turkova, who has her own, uh, YouTube
channel, which I'll leave a link to
in the description box, but many of
you may know, oh, and by the way, if
you enjoy my videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
There are many, I would say,
related languages in the world, uh,
geographically close to each other.
Um, vocabulary syntax and so forth
that are close to each other.
Uh, and, uh, but sometimes this
makes it more difficult to learn the
language because it's so similar.
And so I want to talk today.
Because Ksenia is in the position of
a native speaker of Russian, in fact,
someone from Russia who lived in Ukraine
and learned Ukrainian to, I would say
native, to a native level, but it's
something that's of interest to me.
A because of my interest in Ukraine
and Russia, but also because it comes
up when, say Spanish speakers try
to learn Portuguese or, uh, people
from uh, Spain wanna learn Catalan
or Swedes have to learn Danish.
Uh, there are advantages
and disadvantages.
So my first question is how...
all right.
Question number one, a Russian sp...
someone from Russia who has
never heard Ukrainian in his
or her life hears Ukrainian.
What percentage do they understand?
I would say, hmm, maybe,
uh, maybe about 40 or 50.
Mm-hmm.
, uh, but not more,
especially when people talk.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, so, and also it depends on the
sphere, uh, we are talking about.
So for example, right, if you go to the
restaurant and you want to order something
there, you will understand, of course.
Mm-hmm.
But if you listen, uh, if you are
listening to the radio station,
uh, I'm afraid that you probably
will understand like 30% if you
have never, um, if you have never
heard Ukrainian, because they sp...
uh, they speak very fast and they
use a lot of, uh, words that are
different from, uh, Russian vocabulary.
Uh, that's actually what I faced
with when I moved to Ukraine.
Mm-hmm.
Because I don't have Ukrainian.
I've never been in the
Ukrainian environment.
Uh, I didn't travel to Ukraine
maybe once or twice, just for
several days, and I moved for work.
Uh, although I was not required to learn
Ukrainian because our radio station was
half Russian and half Ukrainian, and I
was allowed to use, uh, Russian language.
Mm-hmm.
, I decided from the first day
that I would learn Ukrainian.
, uh, first out of respect because I
think it's a, it's an essential thing
when you move to another country.
Mm-hmm.
, you need to at least to make an
effort to learn  the language
of that country out of respect.
Mm-hmm.
. Uh, and, uh, also I just like languages
and, uh, I love learning languages.
So I decided to, to start right
away, uh, and, um, , remember
how I started with listening.
Mm-hmm.
because we are, we were preparing to
launch a new radio station mm-hmm.
And to be able to talk with the
guests on radio, on air, I was,
uh, I needed to understand them.
Uh, and that was a
problem in the beginning.
I remember I was listening to, uh,
just some interviews on the radio.
I recorded them and I was sitting
with my teacher and listening to them,
and I didn't understand anything.
Mm-hmm.
I did understand some words, but
I couldn't understand the whole
sentence or I couldn't, uh, tell
what, what they were talking about.
So we just stopped the recordings.
Mm-hmm.
And I asked her, what was that word?
What was that word?
And then my ear get adjusted to that.
Uh, and after that, uh, I started, so
first I adjusted my ear to Ukrainian.
And of course I started reading, but
uh, then I started to, uh, try speaking.
Uh, and, uh, I took classes.
I took classes, uh, very, very
often, uh, the first time.
Right.
Couple of questions because you
said some very interesting things.
First of all.
So 40 to 50% comprehension Russian
speakers who have never heard Ukrainian.
Okay, so 40, 50%.
Is that about the same as say,
Czech or, or are they even less
comprehensible to Russian speakers?
Uh, even less.
Even less.
The interesting thing is that,
for example, if you know Russian
and Belarusian language, you
can understand Ukrainian.
Yes.
If you know Russian and Ukrainian,
you can understand Belarusian.
But if you know only Russian, you can't
understand Ukrainian or Belarusian.
That's a very interesting phenomenon.
but Polish and Czech, even less.
Polish and Czech, even less, uh, Ukrainian
people understand Polish language.
Mm-hmm.
.
Second question or second point was you
made a very important point, and that
is when you arrived in Ukraine, you
decided right away to learn Ukrainian.
I think if you had not done so, if
you say waited a year, you would
probably be less motivated to learn.
I always say that when you first arrived
in the country, that's when you have
to attack the language and then you
develop habits of operating in the
language of the country rather than
operating in your own native language.
Uh, and the third thing you said was
that comprehension was so important
and, and that's why I started learning
Ukrainian, because I was watching Schuster
Live on Ukrainian TV in 2014 following
the events in the Donbas and so forth.
And as you, as you said, in those days,
half the people on television spoke
Ukrainian, half of them spoke Russian.
And I couldn't understand the Ukrainians.
I mean, I can understand some of it.
I felt I should be able to
understand but I couldn't.
And there's also been an evolution
in Ukraine where political
leaders now never use Russian.
Whereas in 2014, a number of the members
of the government even spoke in Russian
all the time, which is no longer the case.
So to what extent though, as a speaker
of Russian and living in Ukraine,
you can communicate in Russian.
Everybody will understand you.
Half the people, depending on where you
are in the country, are native speakers
of Russian, so there would be a tremendous
temptation to just speak Russian.
Was it difficult for you to force
yourself to speak Ukrainian?
Well, I spoke Russian a lot.
I still spoke Russian a lot, but I
tried to speak Ukrainian on radio
with Ukrainian speaking guests.
Mm-hmm.
uh, and uh, I tried to speak Ukrainian
with my Ukrainian speaking friends.
Mm-hmm.
uh, because I had friends, for
example, who spoke, um, they
didn't speak Russian very well.
Mm-hmm.
so Russian was definitely as
a foreign language for them.
They were able to speak Russian,
but uh, they made an effort.
Mm-hmm.
uh, and I tried to speak Ukrainian,
uh, uh, Ukrainian with them.
And also maybe it would be, uh,
interesting that, um, when I tried
to speak Ukrainian on air, since I
was allowed to speak Russian, I did
this, uh, I started, uh, implementing
Ukrainian sentences and phrases.
Mm-hmm.
just one by one.
Uh, for, for example, uh,
I am on there and I have.
Ukrainian guest on the
phone, not in the studio.
Right.
And I had a co-host.
Mm-hmm.
So we spoke Russian
with my co-host mm-hmm.
And we have a Ukrainian speaking
guest, and I tried to ask, uh,
them a couple of questions in
Ukrainian just for, for the start.
Uh, to make it less stressful.
Mm-hmm.
so I would speak Russians and
I switch to Ukrainian to ask
only one or two questions.
Mm-hmm.
Then my co-host, uh, continues,
and, uh, then I say goodbye,
for example, in Ukrainian.
And thank you for, uh, for being with us.
Uh, then, uh, let's say in a.
Uh, I will ask more like three or
five questions in the Ukrainian...
to what extent you continue to mix,
to what extent almost not intending to
mix the two, but you're trying to speak
Ukrainian and Russian words show up to, to
what extent did that continue to happen?
Um, I, I, I mixed it to the, to
some point, and, uh, I, at some.
I was able to be on air, like,
let's say, um, half an hour of the
whole hour speaking only Ukrainian.
With no Russian words.
No russian words at all.
Yes.
No
...
I'm sorry.
No
....
oh, no, no, no ... No ... I think
people who learn Ukrainian, they are
more purist, uh, than people who are
native Ukrainians because I think it's
the common thing within your language,
when you are learning the language, you
are trying to speak pure language and
we are trying to avoid the mistakes.
And that's why I think, uh, those who
learn Ukrainians, they try to avoid
...
a question: as a Russian speaker.
What was most difficult in Ukrainian?
Was it the grammar, the
vocabulary, or the pronunciation?
I would say the most, uh, most
difficult thing for the Russian
speakers is always the pronunciation.
It's very different, uh, in Ukrainian
and the vocabulary in the second place.
Um, Ukrainians are very,
Picky about pronunciation.
Uh, so, you know, they're, uh,
uh, the legends or maybe it's
truth about French people.
I know French, but French
people never corrected me, so
I didn't have that experience.
But I know that, that there is a
stereotype that French people would
correct you, uh, when  when you say
something not in the proper way.
Mm-hmm.
and Ukrainians, same, uh, they're very,
uh, very picky about pronunciation
and about using the right word.
So they would correct you and
sometimes they would make fun of you.
Uh, and uh, that's what, um, I, I
don't like that approach very much.
And I think they understood that,
uh, it was not right because when the
war began, I saw, uh, you know, like
the notes in the restaurants and the
coffee shops, um, uh, Russian, uh,
Speaking people who are, uh, trying
to speak Ukrainian, you are not funny.
Uh, you are wonderful.
Yes.
Uh, so they changed that
approach, uh, which is very good.
But they used to be like that.
So I was afraid to speak Ukrainian and
that's why I worked on my pronunciation.
One more life hack: I have a son
and, uh, he was only three years
old when we moved to Ukraine.
Mm-hmm.
So I tried to read, uh, books to
him in Ukrainian every evening.
And that helped a lot because it's
a simple vocabulary, uh, in, uh,
children's books and, uh, I was
practicing Ukrainian like that.
And also, uh, on the radio
and during my lessons.
Mm-hmm.
You know, I, I always say unsolicited
criticism is absolutely not welcome.
I don't think anyone should correct
another person speaking a language
unless they deliberately ask for it
because all it does is discourage them.
Basically, people just wanna communicate.
I must say, me as a Canadian, no
Ukrainian ever criticizes me or my
Ukrainian, however poorly I speak.
They say, wow, your
Ukrainian is wonderful.
So I think as a Russian speaker,
and they don't know maybe whether
you're from Russia or you're a
Ukrainian Russian speaker, whatever,
they might be more demanding.
for me to...
yes.
Yes.
I think that's important.
...not demanding it all.
They just, whatever I
do is good, you know?
So, yeah.
But I, I think in general, we
shouldn't criticize people.
Mm-hmm.
if they're speaking our language,
I would never, if I speak to
someone in English and they make
mistakes, I would never correct them.
Never correct them.
Oh, I agree with you.
I know, yes.
And so, and the second thing
is vocabulary, as I said.
Uh, yeah, because, uh, in Ukrainian
language, there are a lot of words
that, um, are completely different
from, uh, the Russian ones.
Uh, and, uh, I was, uh, just for fun,
I was, uh, writing some sentences
that are completely different that
they, they don't have any common
word in Russian and in the Ukrainian.
Uh, so, uh, if you want to say,
for example, in Russian and in the
Ukrainian the sentence uh, an educated
person should use, uh, an should
use independent, uh, resources.
Mm-hmm.
In Russian, it would sound like, uh
...
and in Ukrainian it will sound like
And you can't find any word in common in
those two sentences, so it shows you that
the languages are very different, that
it's not some kind of twisted Russian,
uh, there is a stereotype like that.
Uh, actually it's a propaganda,
propagandist myth, uh, in Russia that, uh,
Russian language and Belarusian language
there some kind of twisted Russian.
No, they're not, uh, in fact, Belarussian
is very similar to Ukrainian and I, I'm
not, it's not clear in my mind to what
extent that's due to the original sort
of church slavonic, which was the origin
of these Eastern slavic languages, or the
fact that Belarus and Ukraine were part
of the Polish Lithuanian commonwealth
for three, 400 years, and I dunno who
influenced who, whether the Ukrainian
language influenced Polish or whether the
Polish language influenced the Ukrainian.
But the vocabulary in Polish is closer.
Polish and Ukrainian are closer
in terms of vocabulary than
either one is to Russian.
Russian is kind of the, even amongst
all the Slavic languages, Russian
is a bit of an outlier, right.
Even Slovak and Czech have
more vocabulary in common.
I'm not sure what the historical
reasons for that,you know, are,
but that is in fact the fact.
Yes.
So I think Ukrainian language
was, uh, definitely influenced
by Polish language a lot.
And Polish language, uh, was
influenced by German language.
That's why in Ukrainian, actually
there are a lot of words, uh,
common with, uh, with German roots.
Uh, and you can recognize...
in russian as well, but in Russian as
well, there's lots of German words.
Uh, yes.
Yes.
But above they're different.
They're different.
And from different, and different.
Different, uh, there's
always different eras.
Yeah.
There's always influence.
But people say, well, you know, Russian is
full of Finno-Ugric words or Tatar words.
That's not true.
There's hardly any, there's far more
Western European words in Russian than
Finno-Ugric or, or Tatar origin words.
So I think all of those languages
were influenced by, you know, European
culture, whatever literature words.
Yes, that's true, but actually Russian
language has a lot of Tatar words and,
uh, Uh, uh, Russian language has a lot
of, uh, words from different cultures
and, uh, now, uh, you know, uh, in Russian
politicians, they're trying to fight, uh,
against the influence of other languages.
They want to keep Russian pure, which
is absolutely not possible because,
uh, Russian language has so many words
with, uh, different roots from different
language, which even the words you think
they're pure Russian, but they're not.
Yeah.
No, and that's true of every.
You know, every language is
influenced and, and it'll continue.
You know, I, I'm, right now I'm
learning Persian and Arabic and Turkish
and there have 15% shared vocabulary
for all kinds of historical reasons.
Japanese is full of loan words.
Japanese is 50% Chinese words.
I mean, every, there is no pure,
there is no pure out there.
There's no, no, no pure
people, no pure language.
We live in a, you know, connected world.
So, but that's interesting.
So, uh, after a while then living in
Ukraine, people would assume that you're
Ukrainian if they interacted with you?
Uh, if I speak Ukrainian, uh, some people
they don't believe I was born in Moscow
and, uh, I'm from Moscow, from Russia,
so they, they think I'm Ukrainian.
Yes.
I, it happened to me
living in Washington D.C.
You've, to what extent is there
increased interest in learning Ukrainian.
Amongst Americans, let's say.
any at all or not so much?
I don't know any numbers, but I
definitely see that, uh, a lot of,
uh, Russian speaking Ukrainians
switch to Ukrainian now, and I
have a, I have friends like that.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, for example, I, uh, have a friend
I recorded an interview with her to,
for my YouTube channel by the way,
she's from Kharkiv and, uh, she's
from, uh, Russian speaking family.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, she was predominantly
Russian speaking.
Uh, she knew Ukrainian from
school, but she didn't use it much.
Right.
And, uh, when the war started,
and, you know, what happened with
Kharkiv during the war mm-hmm.
uh, and she made a decision,
she wrote to everybody.
I do remember I, um, received a message
from her, uh, saying that, uh, from
that day I'm switching to Ukrainian.
Uh, I mean, she switched to Ukrainian
with those people who can speak Ukrainian.
So she knew I can speak Ukrainian so
she, um, she sent this message to me.
So a lot of people in the diaspora,
they, uh, they uh, switched to Ukrainian
now, and I see a lot of movement.
For example, uh, like, uh,
camps, uh, summer camps for
kids in Ukrainian and in Kazakh.
By the way, it was the first year, I
live six years here, and it was first
time I saw Kazakh camp, uh, this summer.
Wow.
And, uh, the same thing in Ukrainian
people start, uh, activities
for kids in Ukrainian camps.
Uh, theater, I, by the way, I'm
involved in the new year performance.
I'm playing, uh, in the Ukrainian, uh,
amateur theater with, uh, for, for the,
it's a kids performance for the new year.
Yeah.
Oh, that's very interesting.
You know, and, and, um, Kazakh, I mean,
after all that, it's a huge country
Kazakhstan, huge country and uh, I
don't know how close it is to Turkish.
But, uh, maybe we could
close on that theme.
There, there is no language that's
less important than other languages.
I, I really believe that, uh, a certain
language may be more important to
me because I live in a country where
that language is spoken or because
I have an interest in that culture.
But, you know, objectively all
languages are equally important.
It may be, you know, everyone
knows of Shakespeare or of Tolstoy
because lots of PR behind those
languages, behind those works of art.
Maybe the works of literature from
Kazakhstan, from Ukraine that are equally
valuable, but no one has read them.
No one knows about them.
And so I think it's very important
to treat each language as
being, uh, equally important.
Yes.
And I also wanted to mention, I, I
think it's very important when we are
talking about Ukraine and uh, Ukraine,
uh, as a multicultural country mm-hmm.
uh, I think it's very important
to mention Crimean Tatar language.
Of course.
Uh, and, uh, I actually started
learning Crimean Tatar . I stopped,
uh, because it was difficult and
they didn't have time, and I didn't
have that motivation, uh Right.
But I want to get uh, to that language.
Uh, one day someday.
I have a friend, a very, very
good friend, Crimean Tatar.
Uh, she, uh, uh, she's from
Ukraine and we, uh, at some
point we lived, uh, together.
And, uh, she's Crimean Tatar and she's
a teacher of Crimean Tatar  language.
Uh, and, uh, she was trying to teach
me, I even, uh, still have that notebook
with my notes and Crimean Tatar.
Uh, and, uh, I.
Um, it's a very important, um,
it's very important as a sign of
support of this, uh, population.
Yes.
Because they were always
oppressed by the Russian Empire
and then by Soviet Union and...
and now Crimean Tatar  oppressed
in the, in the next Crimea.
So, uh, I think it's important
to talk about their language
and their culture as well.
Absolutely.
Okay.
Well, listen, I think I have the
impression we could go on forever
talking about languages and language
learning, but, uh, thank you very much.
I think, uh, a lot of my listeners will
understand more about Ukrainian and
Russian and how the languages are similar
and different and uh, you know, I salute
you for wanting to learn Crimean Tatar.
I don't think I'll get there.
I have other languages I've gotta
learn first, but thank you very much.
Thank you, Steve, for having me.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Bye.